my channel is sponsored by hellofresh
which means we will have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone i'm alana welcome to my
channel where today we are talking about
obi-wan the series on disney plus uh
first two episodes just dropped and i
watched them like as soon as i could
basically at midnight um and
i want to talk about what i thought of
it uh also with the context of
i've not liked a lot of the disney
um star wars productions so i really
didn't like boca beaufort like really
really disliked it mandalorian season
one i thought was pretty good cared a
lot less about season two i don't like
really any of the new films very much
except for probably rogue one uh so
while i've been very excited about
obi-wan
because the trailers just look so good
and they just kept tapping into the
nostalgia
in so many ways that i was like damn it
i'm excited uh also like just generally
a little apparent have been concerned
and i still remain that way before we
get into it i do need to address um my
face um i have a big bruise here
i'm very swollen everywhere it hurts a
lot um
i just had uh surgery so uh that's why i
look like this
no calls for alarm i'll leave a link in
the description if you want to have
details about that because i made a
whole video about it on my new channel
which is either going to be called a lot
of irl or lana and friends to have like
stuff that's not to do with video games
or
movies or tv um so i'll leave that in
the description below if you want to
check it out but i'm fine i just look a
little bit badded right now it happens
so overall
i liked it
overall i liked it i think that ewan
mcgregor
is so
attractive to watch on screen i don't
mean that in like a sexual way
or
like even a flirty way i just mean like
he literally demands attention he
attracts attention uh with his
performance and i think that that really
carries the show and is going to
probably until the end i believe it's
only six episodes i have no doubt that
you and mcgregor will be the thing that
like really keeps keeps it all together
and keeps it flowing so i obviously i
like that i liked a lot of the uh
of the like flashbacks
to the prequels like i thought the
opening summary recap was so well made
and i liked his dream um we're gonna get
into full spoilers here by the way
i also thought that uh episode two
ending on
obi-wan realizing that vader is still
alive was oh
such a good place to put that and a very
exciting way to build the series to get
me really invested in because the
relationship between those two
characters especially if you've watched
clone wars is like
so
important in so many ways actually you
can almost blame obi-wan for the outcome
of vader in a way that's super
interesting it is time to talk about
hello fresh are you looking for a spring
refresh try something you take your
taste buds on a trip and explore
different global flavors from your
dinner table with hellofresh with 50
weekly options including a rotating
selection of items at hello fresh market
there are plenty of delicious dishes to
choose from no matter the occasion they
offer so many recipes to choose from
each week you'll never end up in a
recipe rut hellofresh has options for
everyone including family friendly fit
and wholesome and quick and easy meals
so there's something to please even the
pickiest eater at your table
even if that happens to be you you got
this the recipes themselves are all step
by step super easy to follow and come
with pre-portioned ingredients to help
cut out prep time so you can get back
outside this spring not only do recipes
feature produce sourced locally from us
farmers and then delivered when they're
ripe or fresh straight to your doorstep
they also really help me eliminate any
food waste so they taste good they have
a lot of variety they have options for
everybody they eliminate food waste they
use farmers and in partnership with
plastic bank hellofresh helps to
eliminate 10
million bottles from entering the ocean
every year so you get to please your
taste buds please your body in terms of
nutrients please your lifestyle and feel
like you're doing something good for the
environment at least that's why i really
like hellofresh it makes me feel good in
so many ways so use my link or go to
hellofresh.com and use code
pogolanamay16 for up to 16 free meals
plus three surprise gifts across six
hella fresh boxes plus free shipping
gifts include free appetizers free
desserts and free premium recipes thanks
again to hellofresh for sponsoring this
video i
love that it doesn't all take place on
tatooine
obviously it had to in small parts i get
that that obi-wan is looking after luke
on tatooine or looking out for him i get
that that needed to be sandy i'm so sick
of star wars being set in the sand at
this point though that i'm so glad they
went off
really really soon afterwards you love
to see it so i like that we made away
from tatooine and away from sand it's
just so boring i'm so sick of seeing
star wars being
you know universes galaxies
all just [ __ ] sand planets so it's
really nice to be off of sand um
yeah i thought he was brilliant and i
thought some of the
like world design was really cool i like
the setup of the inquisitors trying to
hunt jedis and that actually being a
trap for obi-wan i think is a very
interesting
um premise there and i also like
the context of his situation being that
you know he doesn't want anyone to know
that he's a jedi at this point in time
he's willing to reinforce the um lie
that they're all gone
and so this cat and mouse chase with the
inquisitor or the uh third sister the
second sister i think they call her
third sister
is a very exciting premise that that
could get very very cool and it's also
just nice to see obi-wan being obi-wan
and like going on adventures in
different places and trying to help
people um
so the yeah the the things that seem
very important are the things that i
really like which is i like the premise
slash the plot and where that's headed
i love ewan mcgregor and his performance
i feel like it has a lot of heart and a
lot of soul and a lot of care that has
gone into it already um
but it's also a lot easier to talk about
things that you didn't like and there
are things that i didn't like
first
i do think that leia is extremely cute i
think she's so cute um and i my first
reaction to realizing that it was leia
was like
oh my god that's such a good idea um and
she's just like this sassy little girl
that i do feel like carries a lot of
carrie's energy
um
which is awesome like props to her
at the same time i would say she has
potential to be a little bit annoying
especially because i don't think she's a
particularly great child actor she's not
an incredible actress and i think her
age is wrong she should be about 10
whereas i can't picture this girl being
more than
seven and i think that that makes some
of the delivery of her lines a little
bit strange because you're hearing
something that sounds a lot more mature
coming from a younger person and there
is a big difference between those two
ages so
i think obi-wan a scoring leia very
similar to mando escorting uh baby yoda
or grogu um but i'm fine with that i
like an escort like
that that is like the whole of the last
of us like i'm totally cool with that as
a premise um and i think that leia is
really cute it's a really good idea to
have that happen even if i feel like
she's
yeah potentially could get a little bit
annoying
not a great actress it's okay she's so
young like
they're they're just butts there there
are ifs and buts um where that's
concerned
it kind of also does break some
continuity
when i think about it and i think that
that's sort of likely to happen sort of
numerous times in this show
like wouldn't shouldn't leia have
immediately
mentioned
obi-wan when she's
anyway um
some some definitely some strange
choices there that it's easy enough for
me to dismiss i also thought that
the
chase sequence where there are like four
grown adults
chasing a little girl through a wood
through the woods and unable to catch
her
was so ridiculous just
you couldn't have choreographed that
better
you couldn't
you couldn't put a little bit more work
into that like there's one part where
she slips underneath the tree and then
the goon that's chasing her just smacks
into the tree like it's the three
stooges it's like what there are so many
of them they have her cornered multiple
times and she just sort of like bounces
like she's just like well i'll just go
this way like what
and i guess the way that i can dismiss
that is like alana
it is probably a kid's shirt
it is probably meant to be a kid's show
but then somebody did get stabbed
through the chest i don't know but i
there was multiple times where they had
choreography stuff that i thought was
terrible like i also really thought
uh the second sister again i'm pretty
sure it's second sister
or third sister her
parkour
terrible
why why do they keep trying to shove
popcorn it's like that episode of boba
fett where the guy just spins for no
reason in the middle of combat
it doesn't look good it doesn't make me
think your characters are cool um they
do it multiple times across these shows
it's just cheesy and out of place and
weird and makes it look like she's just
gonna take longer to get somewhere
because she can't stop jumping on walls
like it i don't get why they keep doing
it it's so strange why do they keep
doing parkour
and there are also some things about
that character um let me just look up
her name so that i know that i'm seeing
it correctly give me a second okay she's
the third sister and yeah some of her
lines were just too modern
and i'm not sure if that's a delivery
thing or a writing thing like if that's
on the director the writers or the
actress but
she didn't feel like she fit in star
wars because the way she was talking was
just so
modern like sentences that we would say
in the cadence that we would say them um
and she's also so clean-cut
that
it just felt odd like my first thought
was she's so modern she this is clearly
a person from 2022
and not a person from
the star wars universe um in a way that
just really stood out and i definitely
think that she's going to be very
prominent in the show the fact that
she's only killed one person and he was
a bad guy um to me definitely means that
what's gonna happen here is that she's
going to turn change sides and join
obi-wan um whereas right now she's
clearly seeking him out and hates him
because she was one of the kids who was
present at the great anakin slaughter um
i believe that's true i don't actually
know if that's true that's just the
theory because it means
the opening shot of the show is a
little black girl
training
that's the first person that you see if
i'm correct um my guess is that is her
and obi-wan doesn't save the chi the kid
so she goes up goes sith becomes an
inquisitor and tries to hunt down
obi-wan um but i'm like positive based
on her actions or her inaction that
she's gonna end up teaming up with
obi-wan and being on the good side
and sometimes that can like change the
way that people are hired like maybe she
seems a little bit weird uh as a sith um
i guess technically not a sith she's
just evil um because
she was actually hired for the other
parts that we'll see later and then
you'll be like oh i get it she's great
at that um but i definitely felt that
and i'm positive that she's gonna have
that twist there's just no way she's not
with you know again having her there
trying to establish her is very cool
with all the flippy parkour
and then having her kill a bad guy which
is another thing that i found to be very
ridiculous obi-wan was in the room with
you
for ages he was just sitting by in a box
he wasn't even doing anything he's just
behind a box
and she just kind of talks at him it's
something she's been working towards for
so long and then she just
sort of talks for a bit and then another
guy shows up and she kills him and
obi-wan gets away
ridiculous
so far all of the escapes are not
landing for me as believable is the
thing it's so weird and yeah so i found
some of that stuff pretty cheesy uh i
thought camille then jolly i hope i'm
saying his name correctly too um was
awesome like i really liked the way that
that character was it was a little bit
too fast of an arc where you have like
the good guy who's actually a bad guy
who's actually a good guy that reveals
should come later like i feel like he
should have been episodes down he should
have come back and saved them rather
than having it all happen that quickly
it means it's like hard to really
have it mean anything because that
character hasn't been established in
your head for a long period of time i
definitely liked him
but yeah the pacing that was just a
little bit strange so try to think of
other things that really stood out um
i did feel like some of the city looked
weirdly empty and i felt the same way
about that uh when it came to the
trailers as well um which i think just
like kind of looks a little bit awkward
sometimes when you have these cities
that clearly should be overpopulated
because they're full of stacked
buildings with neon signs everywhere
that would
mostly imply overpopulation but then
there's so few people
in those areas um i find that a little
bit strange for sure
um
and i think it's like it's a budget
thing they're trying to save money right
but but we just have such a or at least
i do i have such an idea of what star
wars should look like that when they try
to save money um by using the volume or
having less extras um it just looks
weird it just things look very awkward
and out of place i'm trying to think of
anything else that i've forgotten i
think that's the main gist of it was
like i definitely liked it i felt like
it had a lot of heart i really like
obi-wan as a character i like the thrust
of the plot um they did some things that
i thought were really really silly just
nonsensical some nonsensical choices i
think
leia has potential to go either way it
could be something that we all fall in
love with or something that we all end
up hating depending on how it pans out
but for now i found it very very
endearing and cute and sweet um as much
as i think it's absurd that she thinks
she could run away from
foreground people and she could somehow
who knows how it doesn't make any sense
um but yeah obviously the climax this is
leading towards is is vader hayden
christensen we know is in the show um
and that is also a very exciting thread
so i wonder how much people would care
about obi-wan if they
had no real knowledge of the prequels
or didn't like the prequels because i
know a lot of people don't like the
prequels but that relationship really is
very powerful um
even for all those movies flaws
so
i wonder if that's like my bias coming
into this is that i really am attached
to all of that especially after watching
all of the animated series yeah right
now i think it's good
i like it
i
don't imagine it's going to be
uh full of exciting fun plot twists or
take itself super seriously the whole
way through
um it's but it is six episodes which
means it's probably gonna be a little
bit cleaner than what we're normally
used to but i think that pretty much
covered everything
things i liked things i didn't like
things i thought were really really
really ridiculous and overplayed um
it's a mixed bag so far uh i mostly feel
like i came away feeling happy and
enjoyed it and we'll continue to watch
the series to see how some of the
threads sort of close up even if i
didn't think it was like perfect i did
think it was very very enjoyable for
sure so
yeah obviously it's a lot easier to talk
about the negatives and the positives
but i still mostly do for very
positively about it would love to hear
what you guys think let me know and a
very big thank you again to hellofresh
for sponsoring my channel
bye